i
[Música]
ah
según últimos datos de la organización
de las naciones unidas casi un millón de
hondureños ha emigrado en busca de
mejores condiciones de vida el éxodo se
da mayormente hacia eeuu en un 82%
españa en un 7 punto 12 por ciento y
gméxico en un 2% las razones
estructurales con las que migran
hondureños son la falta de empleo la
pobreza la inseguridad y la posibilidad
de una reunificación familiar el 70% de
la población de este país vive bajo
condiciones de pobreza desde que salió
la primera caravana en octubre del 2018
alrededor de 20 mil hondureños haya
emprendido esa peligrosa travesía rumbo
a eeuu la última caravana salió hace
tres semanas sin embargo debido a la
ordenanza del gobierno de guatemala de
capturar a los hondureños que ingresaron
de manera ilegal la mitad de estos
migrantes ha retornado al país de manera
voluntaria según datos de la
organización de migrantes en honduras
[Música]
panamá es un país de tránsito por las
embarcaciones que cruzan el canal por su
conectividad aérea e incluso por el paso
irregular de emigrantes por la selva de
darién que es utilizada como ruta hacia
el norte de américa solo en 2019 cerca
de 24.000 personas llegaron por ese paso
fronterizo provenientes de colombia la
mayoría haitianos cubanos de origen
camerunés e indio kobe 19 trastocó esa
cifra y en 2020 sólo se han reportado
cerca de 4500 ingresos irregulares
siendo la mayoría haitiano se les siguen
chilenos brasileños y cubanos las
autoridades han informado que al menos
2.500 migrantes continúan varados en el
país pero el flujo de migrantes no para
a principios de mes entre un pequeño
grupo y dos de esas personas murieron al
poco tiempo de ingresar al país según
informaron las autoridades panameñas uno
de los fallecidos dio positivo en la
prueba de móvil 19 a la par migrantes
centroamericanos que hacían vida en
panamá han regresado a su país porque no
tienen ningún tipo de sustento económico
en este momento el grupo lo encabeza más
de 3.500 nicaragüenses
[Música]
costa rica antes de la pandemia de kobe
19 daba permisos de tránsito a los
migrantes extrarregionales que provenían
de panamá se trataba de un tránsito
controlado entre ambos países a partir
del 19 de marzo cuando las fronteras
fueron cerradas el tránsito se suspendió
y se retomará hasta que se reabran las
fronteras terrestres de costa rica y
centroamérica explicó la dirección
general de migración y extranjería para
atender a los migrantes en tránsito
migración cuenta con dos centros de
atención uno en el sur y otro en el
norte del país actualmente en el centro
ubicado en la frontera norte con
nicaragua se encuentran 125 cubanos y 30
extrarregionales de brasil haití
togo y nigeria en julio hubo en la
frontera entre nicaragua y costa rica
unos 500 migrantes nicaragüenses que se
quedaron varados durante 13 días ya que
el gobierno de su país les exigía una
prueba negativa de kobe que no portaban
otros nicaragüenses estuvieron también
varados en panamá pero finalmente
lograron regresar a su país gracias a un
acuerdo de tránsito de buses entre
panamá costa rica y nicaragua
[Música]